サッブ パパッス アカラナン クサラッス ウパサンパダ
サチット パリヨー ダパナン エータン ブッダナ サーサナン
お願いします それからお布施の行事を唱えます
我々はこの世の中で現れるときは
何一つも持って現れたわけではないのです
何も持たず生まれたんです
生まれるときは赤ちゃんですけど
その体も自分で持ってきたものではないんです
自然界から取ったものなんです
それからも様々なものを我々はいただいて
この肉体を一貫しています
それから考えることも
感情も 自然との関わりによって現れるものです
そこで人間が起こす大きな問題が
私のものという問題なんです
それは自然法則違反なんです
いわゆる宇宙法則違反なんです
最大の罪なんです 私のもの
私の体 あなたの体じゃないでしょう
で 新たなものは何一つもある
何一つもないんです じゃあ考えは私のお考え
いい加減にしろよと言いたい
言わなくちゃあです これも周りから
自然界から教えられたものはオウム返ししているだけなんです
そこで我々は宇宙法則
全存在法則を犯して大罪を犯している
それがたった一言葉で私なんです
私がいると ありえないんです
私のものがあると 私の服
私のお金 私の家 あるわあるわあるわ
それから私のものっていうのは
とにかくたくさんたくさんたくさん取ろうとする
それって多大な迷惑なんですね
自然界に宇宙法則にとっては不正なんです
違法なんです だから生きるっていうことが冗談じゃないんです
かなり強烈な罪を犯しているんで
罪を犯しているという気すらしないんですね
我々思っている罪というのは
嘘をついてはあかんとかね
人のものを取ってはあかんとか程度なんです
人妻に恋を抱くなよとかね
人妻に恋を抱くないと言ってもね
それで私のでしょ 結局は自分の妻と生活しなさい
新型コロナウイルス お前の妻になる相手はいくらいるわけないでしょ
はい それでお釈迦様が助けてあげるために施しということを提案したんです
午後 ちょっと詳しく喋ります
施し ダーナですね しても自分のものをあげてるわけじゃないんです
自分のものやと錯覚したもの
勘違いしたもの と差し上げてるんです
それでやっとあの 罪が柔らかくなるんです
だから仏教では差し上げる人
施しする人が恵まれますよ
当たり前なんです だって宇宙法則破ってないんだから
守ってるんだから だから宇宙法則が
自然法則が その人を育てる
守る 幸福にさせるということをやってくれるんです
それは宇宙法則です それは宗教的にいろんなことを喋ると
なんか宗教的なギシギシになりますけど
これはそうじゃなくて
このユニバーサルプリンシプルという宇宙法則によって成り立つものなんですね
ですから このダーナっていうことがそういうものであると今日理解してください
私のものっていうものがあげる
人のものを取ってあげてもダーナにならないでしょ
当たり前でしょ  はい ...自分のものでなければね
自分のものであると思っているものでなければね
外に咲いている花を取ってきて差し上げたってあまり意味がないんです
自分のものという錯覚がないとね
だから皆さんも だからお金を払って花を買ってきて差し上げる場合は
自分が買ったものだから
俗世間的に自分のものなんです
それを差し上げる はい
そういうことで あのダーナっていうのを
基本的なプリンシプルはそういうプリンシプルなんです
なかなかそれは他の坊さんを習う方々からは聞くチャンスないと思います
はい そういうことで 我々はこの偉大なることをお釈迦様のお誕生を平等にということをお祝い
お祝いするために 偉大な善行をすると
宇宙法則に自然法則に多大な迷惑をかけてきて
違法を犯してきて 罪を犯してきて
それはこのわずかな時間でも
そうではない 清らかな優しい人間になろうではないかということで
このダーマ法行を行います
では 早速今ダーナブリタード
シアルは一回話読みましょう
聞いてください あとで座ぶは一回
それはいい はい 誰もブッダの生命に障害を加えることができる人はいません
いい 誰もブッダの一切に障害を加えることができる人はいません
しぃ 誰もブッダの智慧
衣 食 住 薬に障害を加えることができる人はいません
じい 誰も誰もブッダの三十二大念処
八十種のこと ブッダの体から出せられる一身の光明に障害を加えることできる人はいません
いい ブッダの十八道果は次の通りである
一番 清掃である ブッダの覚を汝に向けるなる智慧
二番 清掃である ブッダの未来世を念ずるとに向けるなる智慧
三番 清掃である ブッダの現在世を念ずるとに向けるなる智慧
これらの三徳を具足した清掃である
六番 ブッダの異サイン身縛よわ
知恵により身よわ また知恵にしだがれ
おおこなわれれる 五番
ブッダの異サインの交互は知恵により
また知恵にしだがれ おおこなわれれる
六番 ブッダの異サインの意図は知恵により
これらの六毒を具足くした世尊である
七番 ブッダに意欲の眼台はない
八番 ブッダに衆生の眼台
眼台はない ない 九番 ブッダに難の眼台はない
十番 ブッダに情の眼台はない
十一番 ブッダに智慧の眼台はない
十二番 阿羅漢が解脱の眼台はない
これらの十二毒を具足した世尊である
十三番 ブッダには遊びがない
十四番 ブッダには走行数がない
十五番 ブッダには智慧の及ばぬところはない
十六番 ブッダには慌てない
十七番 ブッダには歓待の心は少しもない
十八番 ブッダには衆生に際度に関心で観察しないで
無関心であることはない
これらの十八の六聖道与えられた祝福を授られたお方である
ブッダの経意 七仏の経意
七仏の仏への経意 ヴェーパッシ
シッキ ヴェセーブ カグーサーナ
ゴーナーガマーナ カッサパ
ゴータマ ブッダの六聖意に従いての成就は比重数は確かに死んでいる
確実にあり 私はこれらの六聖意を持っているブッダに敬意を表します
真実を伝え ブッダに敬意を表するこの功徳が
私に教えのためのすべての無私の願望の実現願を持たらしますように
じゃあ 今全部話しましょう
読みましょう  読みましょう
はい 一 誰もブッダの生命に障害を加えることができる人はいます
ビ 誰もブッダの異サイン地に障害を加えることができる人はいます
三 誰もブッダの智慧 意
触 触 触 住 逆 に障害を加えることができる人はいます
三 誰もブッダの三途に大祖を恥じ得ること
ブッダのパララは焦られる
一位人の身用に障害を加えることができる人はいます
い ブッダの十八の毒は次のとおりである
一番 世尊であるブッダの過去生を念ずるにむけろなる知恵
二番 世尊であるブッダの未来に生を念ずる
念ずるむけろなる知恵
三番 世尊であるブッダ
ブッダの現在生を念ずるにむけろなる知恵
これらの十徳を具足した聖者である
四番 ブッダの一切智法は知恵により信じよはまた
知恵に従って行くなれど
五番 一切の行は知恵により
また知恵に従って行くなれる
六番 一切の意は知恵により
また知恵に従って行くなれど
これらの六徳を具足した聖者である
七番 ブッダに嫌悪の眼台はない
八番 ブッダに精進の眼台はない
九番 ブッダに貪の眼台はない
十番 ブッダに瞋恚の眼台はない
十一番 ブッダに痴の眼台はない
十二番 阿羅漢が懈怠するの眼台はない
これらの十二徳を具足した聖者である
十三番 ブッダには遊びがない
十四番 ブッダには放逸がない
十五番 ブッダには知恵の用用場のところはない
十六番 ブッダには慌てない
十七番 ブッダには反対の心は少しもない
十八番 ブッダには衆生に裁度に堪して観察しないで
無関心であることはない
これらの十八の浄布施を与えられた
全部全部沙門ラレる仏を与えてある
ブッダの経 四諦仏の経
七覚支の経 ヴィパッサナー
ヴォナーガマナ カッサパ
ゴータマ ブッダの六徳清いに着いての致
尽注すは確かに信じている私はこれらの六徳清を持ている
ブッダに敬意清を寄せます
信心を授たて ブッダに敬意を寄せるこの功徳が
私に恐しのためのすべての無私の煩悩実相をもたらしますように
これはちょっと英語がいきます
このダルマプリが 今は日本語
はい これは マシギさん
はい
No one can endanger the life of the Buddhas. May there be to me likewise!
Buddha's wisdom is unobstructed regarding the past. Buddha's
wisdom is unobstructed
regarding the future. Buddha's wisdom is unobstructed rega
rding the present.
Of the Buddha, the Blessed One, who is endowed with these three attributes,
all bodily actions are preceded by wisdom. All bodily actions
are preceded by
wisdom, are followed by wisdom. All mental actions are
preceded by wisdom, are
followed by wisdom. Of the Buddha, the Blessed One, wh
o is endowed with these,
uh, six attributes, there is no decline of wholesome desire
. There is no decline
of teaching the Dharma. There is no decline of effort
. There is no decline of
concentration. There is no decline of insight into th
e nature of things. There
is no decline of freedom. Of the Buddha, the Blessed One,
who is endowed with
these, uh, with these twelve attributes, there is no laxity
to de- speech or
thought. There is no error in actions. There is not
hing that is untouched by
his wisdom. There is no prolapse of mental activities.
There is no indifference
through ignorance. There is no haste in actions of the freedom. There is no
laxity to deed, speech, or thought. Uh, there is, uh, eighteen
attributes. Homage
to the seven Buddhas, Vipassī, Sikhī, Vessabhu, Phussath
a, Viṣṇu, Kakusandha,
Koṇāgamana, Kassapa, and Gotama. These statements about
eighteen Buddha attributes
are true indeed, and pay homage to the Buddha, Blesse
d One, who is endowed with
these, uh, with these eighteen attributes. Uh, with eightee
n... These statements
about eighteen Buddha attributes are true indeed. I pa
y homage to the Buddha.
Bring me fulfillment of all my selfless aspirations for
the Śāsanā, uh, Dhamma
Cakka Wattana. Kiyo, at one time, Watashi wa kono you ni
kikimashita. Aro doki,
sessan wa Banaresu muki shi san nen ga toride kita tokoro
de aru to, uh, oshie
maremashita. Bhikkhu tachi yo! Uh, sessan ni- Then the Buddha addressed the
group of bhikkhus, "Those two extremes, bhikkhus, should
ne- should not be followed
by wis- wisdom. Which two? Like behavior to attrac
tive sense pleasures, low-worlder
of the evil, ignoble, and unprofitable, and like be- given to self-torment.
Uh, self-torment, there is no decline of wholesome desire,
uh, indeed. Uh, there
is no, uh, this avoider. Uh, these two extremes, extremes
should not be fol-
followed by one who has given up the world. Which tw
o? Like, like behavior to,
uh, attractive sense pleasures, low-worlder of the evil,
ignoble, and unprofitable,
and like, like behavior to self-torment, which is sorry
, ignoble, and unprofitable.
Now, bhikkhu, by avoiding both these extremes, there is merrily goes, fully
under- fully understand, uh, which, which is, uh, merrily
goes, fully understood.
Namely, right view, right thought, right speech, right bodily action, right
livelihood, right effort, right mindfulness, right concentrati
on. This bhikkhu
is merely goes fully under- understood by the Tathāgata, making for vision,
making for knowledge, which leads to tra- to tranquility
, to higher knowledge,
to enlightenment, to Nibbāna. And this bhikkhu is Noble
Truth about suffering.
Birth is suffering, old age is suffering, illness is sufferi
ng, death is suffering.
Association with those we do not love, suffering. Separation
from those we love,
suffering. Not to get what one desires is suffering. I
n brief, the five aggregates,
aggregates are all suffering. In brief, the five aggre
gates, all clinging, are
suffering. And this bhikkhu is Noble Truth of the upr
ising of the suffering,
which is burdened for rebirth, is accompanied by pleasure,
and leads to seeking
satisfaction now here, now there."...namely the cra
ving for sensual pleasures,
the craving for existence, the craving for non-existence.
And this, bhikkhus,
is the noble truth of the cessation of the suffering. Uh,
it is that very craving,
the giving it up, the abandoning it, the release
from it, the detachment from
it. And this, bhikkhus, is the noble truth of the course
leading to the cessation
of the suffering, namely: right view, right thought, rig
ht speech, right bodily
action, right livelihood, right endeavor, right mindfulnes
s, right concentration.
Among these, bhikkhus, not heard before, not heard be
fore by me: vision arose,
knowledge arose, wisdom arose, special knowledge aros
e, light arose. That, this
is the noble truth of the suffering. Among these, bhikkhu
s, not heard before
by me: vision arose, knowledge arose, wisdom arose, special
knowledge, light
arose. That, this is the noble truth of the suffering must
be completely known.
Among these, bhikkhus, not heard before by me: vision arose
, knowledge arose,
wisdom arose, special knowledge, light arose. That, this is the noble truth
of the uprising of the suffering. Among these, bhikkhus
, not heard before by
me: vision arose, knowledge arose, wisdom arose, special
knowledge, light arose.
That, this is the noble truth of the uprising must be give
n up. Uprising must,
has been given up. Among these, bhikkhus, not heard before
by me: vision arose,
knowledge arose, wisdom arose, special knowledge, ligh
t arose. That, this is
the noble truth of the cessation of the suffering. T
hat which is noble truth
of the cessation of the suffering must be realized. Uh, that which is noble
truth of the, uh, cessation of the suffering has been realized.
Among these,
bhikkhus, not heard before by me: vision arose, knowle
dge arose, wisdom arose,
special knowledge, light arose. That, this is the noble truth of the course
leading to the cessation of the suffering. That which is noble truth of the
course leading to the cessation of the suffering must
be, must be developed.
Among these, bhikkhus, not heard before by me: vision arose
, knowledge arose,
wisdom arose, special knowledge, light arose. That which is the noble truth
of the course leading to the cessation of the suffering
must be, has been, has
been developed. And so long, bhikkhus, the vision of knowledge
of these four
noble truths, with the three sections and twelve links
as, as they really are,
by right wisdom, this is not, by right wisdom, this is
not, cannot be contradicted
by an recluse or Brahma or Deva, or by Mara, or by Brahma
, or by anyone in the
world. But when, bhikkhus, the vision of knowledge of thes
e four noble truths,
with the three sections-means and twelve attributes are truth indeed. I pay
homage to the Buddha, bring me full well matter. Uh, th
is is the last birth,
cannot be, uh, I am good, I make that, I was perfect who
had attained the full
supreme enlightenment in the midst of the world. Moreover,
the vision of knowledge
arose to me. I seek well is freedom for me. Uh, this is
the last birth. This
is, uh, now there is no rebirth. The group of b
hikkhus were delighted and rejoiced
at. One of them was Satitha Mo, while this explanation was being added. Uh,
the Buddha said, uh, bless us the one, uh, indeed,
Koninya has understood. Uh,
the bless us the one who is understood, uh, whatever has
the nature of arising,
all of that has the nature of cessation. [clears throat]
Whatever has the nature
of arising, all of that has the nature of cessation. Then,
the Bhikkhava had
proclaimed, "The discourse on the turning of the w
heel of the Dhamma." The other
devas reached, they shouted together, "Cannot be contrad
icted by a recluse or
Brahma, or deva, or by Mara, or by Brahma, or by anyone
in the world." Uh, or
by anyone in the world. Sattu Mara, Dighana, Dewana, Sattan,
Sutwa, Tawa, Desa,
Deva, Yama, Deva, Sudissa, Tussita, Deva, Dimanarad
i, Deva, Paranimitawasawadi,
Deva, Brahmakayika, Deva, Sattan, Nosab, Brahmakayika
, Deva, shouted together.
Shouted together. Uh, thus, in that moment, in that sec
ond, in that instant,
they reached as far as Brahma world, and the ten thousan
d four horses then trembling,
quote, unquote, again, shook violently to and f
ro, and an immeasurable mighty
radiance appeared in the spacing, the devas of glor
y. Then the Bhikkhava added,
this one added once, "Indeed, Koninya has understood. Indeed,
Koninya has understood."
It was at the beginning of the Bhanari Veyya's Koninya. The Bhanari Veyya's
Koninya, having seen Dhamma, attaining Dhamma, known Dhamma
, pledged into Dhamma,
having crossed over, not having put away, and certain tha
t he, having attaining
confidence without depending on others in the tea
chings of religion, spoke to
the Bhikkhava, "May I invite that to leave the world?
May I get the ordination?"
Then the Bhikkhava [clears throat] had said, "Come, bhikkhu, the Dhamma has
been well expounded. Practice the holy life rightly fo
r making an end of suffering."
So this came to be ordination along with the Bhanari Ve
yya Koninya. Dhamma Cakka
Wattana Sutta finished. Uh, Anatta-lakkhana Sutta. At one time, sir, homage
to the consort, the Worthy the Buddha, Enlightenment and
the Buddha Supreme.
At one time, sir, the Bhikkhava was dwelling in the Banarisatriy
a Pasibarna.
There, the Bhikkhava addressed the group of bhikkhus, "Oh,
bhikkhus!" The bhikkhus
answered, "Patanedi." Then the Bhikkhava spoke thus: "Matter,
bhikkhus, is not
the self. If matter, bhikkhus, were the self, then matter
would not end sickness,
and one cannot stop matter. [background noise] Thus le
t matter be thus for me,
let matter not be thus for me. Feeling, bhikkhus, is no
t the self. If feeling,
bhikkhus, were the self, then feeling would not end sickn
ess, and one cannot
stop feeling. Thus let feeling be thus for me, let feeling
not be, not be thus
for me. Perception, bhikkhus, is not the self. If perception
, bhikkhus, were
the self, then perception would not end sickness, and one
cannot stop perception.
Thus let perception be thus for me, let perception not
be thus for me. Mental
formation, bhikkhus, is not the self. If mental formation,
bhikkhus, were the
self, then mental formation would not end sickness, and
one cannot stop mental
formation. Thus let mental formation be thus for me,
let mental formation not
be thus for me. Consciousness, bhikkhus, is not the self. If consciousness,
bhikkhus, were the self, then consciousness would not end sickness, and one
cannot stop consciousness. Thus let consciousness be thus
for me, let consciousness
not be thus, thus for me. What do you think of this, bhikkhus?
[clears throat]
Is matter permanent or impermanent? Impermanent body. Imper
manent or suffering
or happiness, suffering body. Impermanent, suffering, grabbed by nature, is
limited, fading to return. This is a mind. This are min
d, this is not self for
m
e."...Uh, what is a feeling? Permanent or impermanent? Imperm
anent and binding.
Impermanent, suffering or happiness, suffering bi
nding. Impermanent, suffering,
corruptible by nature, is delivering to regard this. Thu
s, this is a mind. These
are mind, this is self for me, not willing binding. Is
perception, bhikkhus,
permanent or impermanent? Impermanent and bi
nding. Impermanent is that suffering,
corruptible by nature, is delivering to regard the thu
s. This is a mind. This
are mind. This is self, self for me, not willing binding
. This mental formation,
bhikkhus, permanent or impermanent? Impermanent and b
inding. Impermanent, suffering
or happiness, suffering binding. Impermanent, suff
ering, corruptible by nature,
is delivering to regard the thus. This is a mind. These are mind. This is a
not self for me. Uh, consciousness, bhikkhus, imperm
anent or permanent or impermanent?
Impermanent and binding. Impermanent is suffering or happiness,
suffering binding.
Impermanent, suffering, corruptible by nature, is delivering
to regard the thus.
This is a mind. These are mind. This is self for me, not
willing binding. Uh,
therefore, bhikkhus, whatever matter there is, be it past
, future or present,
in what of what? Gross or subtle, low or of the far or near. Uh, [coughing]
all kinds should be as regarded, regarded, uh, this, thus.
This is a mind. These
are mind. This is self for me. Uh, therefore, bhikkhu
s, whatever feeling there
is, be it past, future or present, in what of what? Gross or subtle, low or
of the far or near. Uh, feeling of all kinds should be
as the reality by, uh,
this is not mind. These are mind. This is not se
lf for me. Uh, perception, therefore,
bhikkhus, perception, uh, there is to be it past, future
or present, in what
of what? Gross or subtle, low or of the far or near. Percept
ion of all kinds
should be as regarded by right wisdom. This is not mind
. This is not, this is
not self for me. Therefore, bhikkhus, whatever mental formation there is to
be it past, future or present, in what of what? Gross or
subtle, low or of the
far or near. Uh, mental formation of all kinds should be
as regarded by... This
is a wisdom. This is not mind. This is not self for
me. Therefore, bhikkhus,
whatever consciousness there is, be it past, future or
present, in what of what?
Gross or subtle, low or of the far or near. Consciousnes
s of all kinds should
be as regarded by this is wisdom, this is not mind. This
is not self for me.
Uh, there was a so saying, bhikkhus, the well taught nobl
e disciple is disgusted
with the matter, disgusted with the feeling, disgusted with the perception,
disgusted with the mental formation, disgusted with the, uh, consciousness.
So being consciousness, uh, these statement about everythi
ng, uh, so saying,
bhikkhus, the well-taught noble discipl
e-イーズディスガズディスガズディスガズディスガズメンタルフォーメーションディスガズディスガズコンシャスネス
ソーセイビクス ザウェルトージョーノーベルディサイプレ is a フリーフラウンディアーサワ
ウェストサウスレプリンゲー
ヴィーダラナパリタ ダンマチャッカポタナソッタ
アナタレクナソッタトッソッタニ
フィニッシュデッド オワリマショ
サードサードサード はい
では法要の後半 これから始まります
えーと まあ早く終わりたいとは思ってますので
お経などなどは省略いたします
もしかすると 4時からコロナが働く出しかもしれません
ですから 今コロナウイルスは寝ている時間です
大丈夫です はい 今日私たちはね
お釈迦様のウェーサーカ祭りをね
お釈迦様のウェーサーカ祭ではないんだけど
ウェーサーカっていうのは月の名前です
それではお釈迦様特権取ってるみたいですね
ウェーサーカ祭というんですね
ウェーサーカとは月の名前で
お釈迦様の誕生 成道 涅槃を
我々はそこを思って なんとか法要を行って
心清らかにするための
法要として使っているんですね
はい お釈迦様の誕生日をお祝いというならばね
でっかいケーキを置いてお釈迦様の前でカットしてね
という誕生日じゃないんです
そういうことはやらない
で ブッダっていうのは世の中で一人しか現れませんし
人々には決して発見できない真理を世に遠慮なく発表するんです
で その教えたくさんありますけど
今回は私がこのほとんど言ってないテーマがありまして
この布施とは何なのかと
それはその項目を避けてずっと避けてきたんですね
で 執着捨てなさいという話をしても
物の見事に誤解されてますから
布施について語ってもね
同じく見事に誤解する可能性があります
では また改めて始まります
では 布施についてはあまり語らなかったんですね
で 午前中 ほんのちょっと一般的にはお坊さんたちから聞くチャンスは絶対ないポイントを教えたんですね
で それを再び言いますけどね
生命っていうのは 輪廻転生するときは何か持っていくわけじゃないんです
持っていくって 自分のものと言えば業だけなんです
業っていうのは煩悩のエネルギーですからね
それは精神的なエネルギーであって
物質的なエネルギーではないんですね
だからそのエネルギーによって生まれてから
もう世の中にある物質を取り入れて
取り入れて取り入れて
体を作るんですね だから取り入れるためには業が必要なんですね
だから業の力に適した物質が
いわゆる掴める物質を使って使って体は構成していくんです
ですから この全部この借りたもので
我々はエネルギーを借りているんですね
借りたものをどうしても返すことになります
自分では返すつもりがあろうがなかろうが関係なく
それ返すんです ですから
今の自分が何やというと
いろんないっぱいものを持っているしね
一番最初に体を持ってるし
これは私の体だと 持っていると思っているんですね
体は私の体だから 体のためにまた他のものは必要になるんですね
肉体のために 家が必要なのは
車が必要なのは肉体のためなんです
それで体ってあなた持ってきたのかって
体持ってきてないんです
体の物質はすべてこの地球の物質なんです
だから地球の物質は結構ありますけど
五に取れるものだけ まあ取ってるんですね
動物なんか見ると 動物はいろんな餌を食べて生活しますね
でもどんな餌を食べられるかで
そこで決まりがあるでしょうに
カラスは動物を殺して肉を食べてますけど
カラスはいくら頑張っても亀を食べられませんね
で 時々ヘビは顎が外れますから
自分もヘビの体が小さい丸いんだからね
それより大きいネズミやらカエルとか飲み込めるんです
顎が下がって中に入ります
しかし あの 例えば大きいニシキヘビとかはね
あの鹿とか見たら じゃあ食べてやろうと食べちゃう
食べ取るんです それで顎が上がって引っ張られて
とにかく食べようとすごい苦労するんです
その場合は お腹に入ってもあちらこちら足とか出っ張ってるんです
だからまあ 1ヶ月間  2ヶ月間ぐらい食べないんだからね
それで消化するまでは
ですから そういう例で考えてください
五に何でも取ることはできませんよ
だから五に取ることできるものは取っちゃいますね
例えば 身体障害のある方々がいるでしょうし
誰だって障害を持っては生まれたくはないし
我々も人々 障害の人々は作りたくはないしね
障害を持って生まれたっても
何かしらこの障害ではなく
健体の体でいてほしいっていうのは誰だって願いますけど
どうもそううまくいかないね
あの よく派手なことを考えると
背が高くならない人々ような小人の人々はスリランカでもグループがいるんですよ
これぐらいしか背がないんですね
他障害は全くない 知識もすごくあるし
能力もあるし 体は背が伸びない
だから何したってこれは伸ばすことできないんですね
だからそれには医学的に何とか何とかホルモンがない
何とか何とか脳の中でこうあれやこれや説明するんだけど
なぜそもそもそうなったのかというね
今更ことが起きてから説明できますよ
だから 業が物質を引っ張っていると
間でどうもなんか引っ張ってない
引っ張られなくなっちゃったんですね
その結果 体に何か問題あるとかね
だからそれが余計に高い人であっても
もう食べても食べなくても体が太る人もいろいろいるんですよ
だからことが起きてから
これは遺伝子のあれやこれやとかね
言ってますけど 我は私が聞くのはなんでそもそもそうなったのかと
もともと一個の細胞の時
なんでそうからでしょうに
だから業っていうものはありまして
業が自分に取れるものを物質取って体作っていくんです
それで我々作る一番大きい問題は
どこかで頭がいかれちゃいますね
どこかで頭イかれて一番最初に最初に思うのは
これ私の体よ 私の体というために
私が別にいなくちゃあかんでしょうに
別に私がいないんです
そこをすごい屁理屈でしょ
例えば これは私の髪ですと言えますね
だって別に私がこちらにいるんだから
私の体ってどういうのですかね
そこから頭イカれちゃいますよ
簡単な話 単純な話 私の体といったとたんもうイカれてるんです
それからあらゆる生きる苦しみが生じてくるんです
私を蹴った 私を私のことを笑っちゃった
私のことを馬鹿にしました
お母さんが私のことを無視しちゃった
お母さんが私は面倒くさい人やと言われたとかね
いくらでも苦しみはもう作りたい放題
無限に作れます だから最初に頭イカれたことが問題なんですね
この私って気持ちが単語がないんで
初めは子供たちに単語ないんです
単語ないんだけど 正々堂々と私という気持ちがあるんですね
そこからイかれること始まるんですね
それからそれも頭イカれたら何するかわからない
頭イカれた人やることはどうせやってはいけないことなんです
でないとイカれていると我々知らないんです
例えば ある人はすごく行儀作法よく美しいと私と違ってね
美しいものの見事な言葉を喋ったり
人の気に障ることは絶対言わないで
しっかり頑張って仕事もして
人に頭おかしいと言わないでしょ
我々頭おかしいというのは変な言葉を使う
言ってはいけないことを言う
あるいはこの場でそんな言葉を使わないところでそうする
やっちゃう ここでこんなことをやるなよというところでやっちゃい
やってしまう で 頭おかしいと言うんですよ
ですから 頭がおかしいというためには
そういう変なことをやらなくちゃいけない
やってはいけないことをやらなくちゃいけない
いわゆる仏教的に言えば
不善行為をやらなくてはいけないんです
それでどんな生命も最初からイカれちゃったんだからね
あのワイリングはなんか間違って差しちゃったんだからね
進むべきところを逆に行く
逆に行くべきところを進むということになっちゃうんですよ
ワイリン間違ってワイリンしちゃうと
ですから 私という気持ちがある
人がやることは至って簡単で
極端的に言えば一切間違っています
私という気持ちがあったら
その人はイカれているんです
ですから やることは何であろうとも
そんなことをやってはいけませんよと
だから我々にとってはやっていいこと
やって良いことをやらせるために
ものすごく家畜動物は昔
車荷車を運ぶとき 人が乗るとき
動物を使ってたでしょうに
そんな感じで無理やり動物扱いしなくちゃあかんです
自分ではやりたくないんです
例えば車を引く 昔のね
車を引く 馬でもロバでも牛でもね
インドなんか牛でしたからね
牛がいつ私に 私に車を私に頼んで引かせてくれるでしょうかと
待っていないんです 牛は餌を食べて楽に生きていきたい
だから我々は首にロープをつけて
牛の場合は鼻に穴まで開けて
馬の場合は口になんか鉄のね
なんかハーネスと言いますけどね
それつけちゃって 考えて口の間で歯がないところで鉄の棒が入っていて
どれほど気持ち悪いかと
馬の場合な 後ろの方で歯がないところありますからね
それで馬を走らせるは
馬に乗るは 馬 馬車引いてもらうは
我々人間にしたっても嘘をつくなよと
人に優しくしなさいよと
言うためには あれぐらい苦労しなくちゃあかんです
他人のものを取るなよと
汚れた言葉を使うなよと
人に迷惑をかけなよという道徳リストをやらせてもらうために
あの家畜動物のようにその人を抑えて
口にハーネスを入れて
苦労しなくちゃあかんです
それでもチャンスがあったら馬は逃げる
だから人間っていうのは見張っておかないと
やりたい放題悪行為をする
見張って管理すると立派な人間でいる
はい そういうことで 論理的に至って単純なこと
最初からいつかわからんだけど
頭イカれちゃったんです
私という気持ちが生まれたんです
もうそれからアウト それからやることはすべて不善行為
良いことをさせたければ
もう牛だったら穴 鼻に穴を開けて何か輪っか入れて引っ張らないと
あれ 相当痛いんです だからそういうことはあまりロバにはしないんだから
ロバっていうのはあんまり荷物を運んでくれないね
ものすごい苦労するんですよ
ちょっと進んでもらうためにちょっと止まるんです
すぐ止まるんです だからロバにも耳にでも穴をつけてロープでも糸でも入れて引っ張るならば
一個でロバ頭悪いんだから
そうすると鳴くだけ だからそれもうまくいかない
はい だから人間も同じことですよ
脅して脅して良い人間にしなさいと言うんです
法律が必要し 警察が必要し
裁判制度が必要し それで莫大なお金がかかるし
何やってる？なんで人はね
人を犯したり 空き空き家でなんて言いますか
家に入ったり 痴漢をしたり
なんでそんなことやるのかと
そういうことやらなかったら警察はいらんでしょうに
人を殺したり 裁判制度もいらんでしょうに
だから生命がイカれたからなんですよ
軍隊が必要です そのお金並みじゃないんですね
軍隊を維持するために使うお金
裁判制度 警察システム
冗談じゃないんです だから
皆イカれてます だからそれぐらい大変なんです
良いことをしてもらうために
それで問題はですね 私という気持ちが生まれたら
次に私のものが出てくるんです
赤ちゃん頃は私はいるんだけど
あまり私のものはないんです
で よくよくチェックすると
じわじわと私のものが現れてくるんです
それは赤ちゃんにガラガラって言うんですか？なんか音を立てる
何かガラガラあげちゃう
大丈夫 ちょっと振って興味ないとか落としたり色々するでしょ
で 慣れちゃうとガラガラ諦めるんだけど
これ手を出して出して取ろうとするでしょ
あ もう私のものができているんです
それでそれはお母ちゃんが取ってこうやってやっていると
手を出すんですね 手を出して自分のものにしようとするんです
赤ちゃんたちにもやっぱり取る
何のためか赤ちゃんはまだわかってないんです
だから何かあげちゃうと取る
取って口に入れてみる
例えばボールペンをあげたら見せたら手を出して取る
取ったら これ何のためか赤ちゃんはわからないんで
口に入れてみる ね 口に入れてみて
それから興味ないと落としちゃうんです
ですから この私という気持ちが生まれたら
私のというものに出てきて
赤ちゃんはそれほど怒れてないんだから大丈夫
どんどんどんどん怒りのあれレベルがアップになるんです
それで全部私のもの 私のもの
これも欲しい あれも欲しいと取りまくるんです
それでたくさん自然のものを取るためにいろんな工夫をする
学校に行く 勉強する 学校に行って人間幸せじゃないんでしょ
学校がない動物たちは幸せに生きているでしょうに
学校に行くのはどんなからくりをやって自分のものにすることができるかという
いわゆるどうすれば金儲かるのかと
それで人間の社会はうまくいったかというと
うまくいってないんです
カラス社会はうまくいってるんです
ネズミ社会もうまくいってるんです
学校はないから 取ること
盗むことの訓練を受けてないんです
で この宇宙の法則 宇宙のエネルギーを私たちには貸してあげるんです
で どれぐらい借りられるのかっていうことは
その生命の業によります
例えば銀行って言ったら
銀行には 1兆円  2兆円 10
兆円もお金あるかもよ
銀行は金貸してあげる
そこであ 銀行に 1兆円
じゃあ私に 1兆円貸してくれ
じゃあくれないでしょ
私の力によって 何歳ですかと
何のためにどんな商売に使うのか
あれ 何て言いますか 担保っていうんですか
権利書 いろいろね 土地どれくらい持ってるの？そこで計算して
じゃあまあ百万貸してあげると決める
だから 自分の力によって
銀行には何兆もお金あるかもしれませんだけど
何兆もないと思いますけど
あの せいぜい百万のローンできただけでしょう
だから それをもっとスケール
この例え話でスケール拡大したら
大自然界に大宇宙にどれぐらいエネルギーある？想像を絶するエネルギーでしょ
だから自分がちょびっと僅かなちょっと借りているんです
そこで借りたものは返さなくちゃいけない
そこに私のものだと自分が勝手に権利書を書くと
これは許すがい罪でしょ
例えばね 今日本の新しい法があってね
土地とかは買うお金なくても
まあ十年か五十年のあれ
なんかレンタルできるんですね
それで建物を作って商売できます
ちゃんと十五十年か二十年か
その二十年かな そこ終わっちゃうと元に戻って更地に戻して返さなくちゃあかん
自分たちはもう二十回建物作ってもいいんです
後で全部返さなくちゃいけない
そんな感じで 大宇宙にはいくらでもエネルギーがありますけど
我々は業によってちょびっとほんの僅かなものを借りて使っていて
それを返さなくちゃいけない
そこで自分が権利書を書く
二十年契約でレンタルした土地なんですけど
しっかりした権利書を書くと
これで偽造でしょ それ振り回すと犯罪でしょ
我々みんなその犯罪しています
これは私の体 私の服 私の建物
私の家 私のお金 私の私の私のという言うたびに法則を犯している
それについて働くたびに法則を犯している
法則を犯せば 生きることはすごく苦しくなるんです
船で海を渡れます しかし
我々は船の法則を破る
どうなる？遭難するだけ遭難っていうんですかね
その場合は  あるいは飛行機で空を飛べる
飛行機に乗った人は飛行機に関わる法則破る
どうなる？車を運転する人は車運転に関わる法則を破る
だから法則というのは破ってはならんものという必要すらないんです
それで車みたいなちっちゃな出来事じゃなくて
大宇宙界の法則を破ろうと考えた時点でおかしいんです
破っているんです だからその人は苦しむんです
車を運転する場合 車線を間違って運転するともうおっかないでしょうに
それで事故っちゃったら道路のせいと言える
あれは道路のせい 自分が車線を間違ったことは関係ないんです
ガードレールにぶつかっちゃ
こちらガードレールあったんだからでしょうにって言っちゃっていいんですかね
電信柱に車ぶつけて それ壊れちゃったら政府に弁償しなくちゃいけないんでしょ
文句を言う なんでこちらに
で こういう柱 電信柱つけたんですかねと
政府に訴えていいんですかね
我々は生き物はそれやっているんです
宇宙に文句言ってるんです
大自然に文句言ってるんです
で だから私 私のというところからこの問題は起きたんです
他宗教は神様に の気が立ったと言うでしょ
微妙に似ていますけど
でもあまりにも幼稚っぽい話なんです
神様の気が立ってなくて
大宇宙法則の気が立ってるんです
で 別に気が立ってないんです
海を例えにすると 海でボートに乗っていて
ボートは乱暴に使う するともう沈んでしまうでしょう
海が何も悪いことをしていないでしょ
だから仏教は神様の妄想概に使わない
神様が腹が立って人に罰が当たると言って
なんか変ですね 自分が乱暴にボートを扱ってエンジンも停止しちゃって
もうやられちゃったと
船がボートが転覆しちゃって死んじゃったというと
海のせいと言えないでしょうに
正しく丁寧にボートを操縦したならば
海ってありがたいでしょうに
ちゃんと運んで楽しがませてくれたんだから
ですから この宇宙法則はね
我々に罰を与えていないんです
そこら難しいね 理解するのは
誰かが罰を与える必要ないんです
そこで自分が不幸になる
だから乱暴に運転すると
この人の運転は乱暴です
だから罰を与えなくちゃいけない
こちら電信柱を置いておこうってことはないでしょ
あるいは反対側から車を横
横の道路から車を飛ばそうと
だからそちらグリーンライトライトで
こちら赤で これ乱暴な運転だから赤
もう信号を飛ばしちゃう
それでぶつかるでしょうね
罰が当たったんですかね
ないんです 自己責任でしょう
その瞬間で罰が当たるんです
そういうわけで 生命には生きることは苦
期待通りにいかない 期待したことで間違いです
はい それで私の私のと言うんだから
年取るのものすごい嫌なんですよ
私の家作っちゃったんだけど
自分がもう歳であともう年でもう死んじゃうんだから
ああ まあこの家を捨てていかなくちゃって苦しむんですね
だから長生きする方法はないのかと
だから死のことすら人間には最大の苦しみになっているんです
なぜならば 私の命だから
私の体だから で この言葉を使うたびに
信じられない この嘘 この犯罪
人に対する犯罪ってちっぽけなものです
無制限の無料の宇宙法則に対して
これはもう冗談じゃないです
だから常に常に その瞬間
その瞬間 人々は自分の悪行為の結果を受けているんです
それでお守りをぶら下がったからといって
金曜日か日曜日教会に行ったからといって問題解決しません
間違いを直さなくちゃいけない
ですから ブッダの幸福の道は
大体 1番目 お釈迦様は布施というものを教えているんです
道徳などなど瞑想などのはそれからなんです
私はそれを今までそれ喋らなかったんです
利害関係があるんだから
言ってることはいつでも反対
逆に理解するんだからね
なぜ布施がそんなに一切の幸福の入り口
解脱の入り口 究極の安穏の
入り口 ファーストラップ
車のレースだったらラップ20とかね
あるでしょうに ファーストラップ
施しなんです 施しをする場合は
自分のものは他人にあげる
自分のと思うものは何でもいいんです
貸して返してあげる そこでいくらかの恐ろしい犯罪のなんか和らげてくる
すごい借金している人がちょこちょこでも借金返せば
借金のあれが少なくなるでしょう
でも借金と違って これは結構幸せになります
宇宙法則を破らない場合は
宇宙は別に前と同じくいるんです
しかし 自分は守られているんです
悩み 苦しみがなくなっちゃうんです
怯えがなくなるんです
私は将来何食べて 何食べて生きてるのかとか悩まなくてもいいんです
もう自然界でいくらでもありますから
無限にありますから 法則を破らなかったら
全然問題ないんです だから施しを行う人は幸福で豊かで
明るく生きられますよ
長生きもできる 別に命が寿命長くなるわけじゃなくて
ずっとプログラム終わりまで生きられます
ほとんど人々は自分のプログラム終わりまでは生きてないんです
途中でカチッと終わる
電池が切れちゃう で 長生きというのはそういうことで
大体人間には軽々と人はいられますし
軽々と法則を破らなかったら結構長生きできます
で まあ百五十二百年ぐらいいた
生きたければ 大体はね
十歳の時から始めなくちゃあかんです
法則を守ること 今更遅いんだからね
それの話は置いておきましょう
できればちっちゃい子供の時に法則を教えたら
その子はそれを守るならば簡単に歳はいくんです
何の病気にもかからない
それでユニバーサルプリンシプル
ユニバーサルローというものは守らなくちゃいかん
だから私のものは犯罪ですね
そこで自分が私のものという気持ちをなくしちゃうんです
あげることで それ理解して施しを行ってみてください
これは何々お坊さんが顔
顔色が可愛いんだからあげますとか
そんなことじゃないんです
あのお坊さんが可愛いんだから
あのお坊さん若いんだからとか
そんなことでしょ あ すごいお年寄りの大長老だから
じゃあお布施しますと
ハチャメチャ法則破ってるんです
あのお坊さんが有名だから
ダーナになってないんですよ
あのバカたちは知らんんですよ
だからお釈迦様が比丘たちにこの施しを期待して説法するなよ
なぜ法則違反です それは
坊主 坊主にしたってもね
お布施もらいたいと思ったら法則違反でしょ
だってその場合にも私のものって法則でしょ
そう 微妙なんです で 説法するお坊さんは説法する
だから信者さんが説法したからお布施しますって言っちゃうと
アウト 残念です 法則破ったんです
信者だった人に それをお金で清算しようと思ったんです
真理まで侮辱しちゃったんです
宇宙法則どころじゃないんです
ですから お布施も仏教世界では単純明確に明確に言うんだけど
すごい難しいんです 愚か者には理解できるものじゃないんです
私は今日言っちゃおうと思ったんです
腹が立って 甘く見るなよと
お釈迦様がただ頭イかれてこんなことをおっしゃってるわけじゃないんです
一言葉 一言葉 もう信じられないぐらい深いことをおっしゃっているんです
だから本当のお布施の場合は
そのベーシックプリンシプルを覚えて
私のものはこれ 私の可愛いペンだよ
これ結構もう気に入ってますよと
初恋の人からもらったプレゼントやと
そうすると私の気持ちすごい強いでしょ
誰かにあんたこれ持って行って
それだけ 自分がこのバリューオブ物の価値にプラスエモーショナルバリューもあるでしょ
初恋の人からもらったペンですけど
相手にとってはただのくだらぬガラクタのペンでしょ
でも自分にとってはすごい価値があるんですね
じゃあ持っていって 持っていって
若い子がまあまあ結婚なんとか約束したいんだけど
なんて言いますか 婚約
婚約したいんだけど 指輪買うお金もないと言ったら
自分が ああ まああの これ私は結婚するって旦那からもらった指輪だから
はい これ持って使って
何の躊躇もなくあげると
自分のは自分が結婚式の輪っかだから
エモーショナル価値がありますよ
だからエモーショナル価値っていうのは
私のという強い強烈です
取ったらただの輪っかですね
金属の その人にあげる
すると一個だけでは あ
いいや 旦那のものを取ってあげると
あげちゃう はい そこでそれはダーナになります
なぜかというと 私のということで犯した罪を直したいんです
ですから 朝も言ったんでしょ
人から借りてあげても意味がないし
人のものをあげても意味がないし
公園にある果物やら花取ってきてお布施したっても意味がないし
まあ山に行って果物を取ってあげるのは意味がありますけど
何か自分が怒られた頭で自分のものを自分のものと思ったものをあげなくちゃいけない
もらったお坊様 じゃあ私がもらったと思ったら
そのお坊さんがアウト
それはそちらの責任 私は結構お布施もらいますよと思ったら
さようなら その人はかわいそう
宇宙法則破っているんです
宇宙法則破った人は不幸になるのはどうしようもないんです
自然は我々に罰は与えません
海は人に罰を与えません
海でセーリングしているボートの人のボートの操縦仕方によって不幸になるだけ
ですから お釈迦様は言っているのは
誰も私たちには罰は与えません
ノーバディパニッシュですよ
パニッシュメントというのはナチュラルナチュラルプロダクション
自然に起こるんです 自然がやるんじゃなくて
自然に起こる いわゆる当然当たり前
ですから 施しを行う人々は幸福になるということは当たり前
当然のことです しかし
期待しないでください
そうするとまたどうなる？また破っちゃうんです
はい そういうダーナは仏道 のダーナシーラ
バワナという３ステージで説明しますからね
ダーナ１ シーラは２ 戒律は２
は三 それで涅槃の道 ダーナは今日で全て語りました
それでたまたまお遊びに
ダーナについてお釈迦様がおっしゃった
神々におっしゃった経典一つ二つ紹介します
神々だから当然馬鹿でしょ
ある神がこれデーヴァダですか？デーヴァダッタですか
デーヴァタ女神ですね
アドティスミンアガーラスニャンニーハルディバージャナンタントスホーティアッハヤノーチャヤンタッタダイハティという歌を歌うんですね
火事になってる家で 家から飛んで何か飛び出す
家から取り出したものだけ自分の役に立つんだと
残りは全部灰になるんだよ
なんて当たり前のことね
それで次の偈が出てくるんですね
エヴァンアーディットコローコ
この世界は いわゆる生命は燃えていますよ
火事になってますよ もうそろそろ灰になりますよと
どうやって ジャラーヤマラニーナチッ老いることと死
瞬間も何にストップでしょ？瞬間瞬間老いるんですね
だから燃えているんです
死の瞬間で終わり はい
灰になって まあ灰って物理的な灰ではないんだけど
まあそれで終わり だからこの間にもう家が燃えている
いわゆる命がね 何か取ってくださいと
ニーハレーではダーネーナ
施しということで 品物を何か取り出してくださいと
いわゆる施しすると それは自分のためになるんだよって意味なんですね
ディンナンオーティシュニーハタン
与えたものがちゃんと
だから与えたものと与えるということは
大自然界から自分が何か使えるものをいただいているのですから
使えるんです だから自分に使えるものはすべてお布施したものだけなんです
という意味の偈ですね
これはもうこの神の 言葉ですけど
お釈迦様の言葉はどこから入っているかちょっとわからない
これはミャンマー版だからね
なんと ディンナンスカパランホーティ
良い結果になるのは施しした時だけやと
ナーディンナンホーティタンタ
施ししない人にはそんな結果はないんだと
苦しいだけ チョーラーハラン
施ししない人々の財産は自然になくなりますよと
チョーラーハランで泥棒に持っていく
あるいは政府が税金で取り上げる
アッギダーティ 火で燃えてしまう
何かしらなくなる そこでアタアンテーナジャハティサリーランサパリガハン
何やっても最後には自分すべての持ち物
財産を捨てて 体が体まで捨てなくちゃあかんやと
死ぬ時は 死ぬ時 自分も何もないんです
だから面白いでしょう
私の家 私に取って言っちゃっても
息が止まった瞬間で自分のものじゃないんです
どんな国でも同じことです
すごい豪華な家の人は
最後に病気で病院に運ばれちゃって
そこでいろんな機械につなげて
なんとなく息をしている
そこであのあれ メーターつけてますから
心臓と酸素の濃度 あれこれチェックするね
そこでいきなり心臓の鼓動が横に線になっちゃうでしょ
あった あの瞬間で終わり
あの財産はあの人のものじゃないんです
うん 多く持っていたっても
その人も何もないです
エータダンジャメーダービ
これの智慧のある人はそれを知って
ブンジェイヤダデダデタチャ
自分でも財産を正しく使いなさいよと
財産楽しみなさいよと
それから開けなさいよと
どうせ死ぬ時は自分のものじゃないんだからね
使えるのは生きている間だけなんですね
銀行口座の桁がいくら長くたっても
使えるのは生きている間だけでしょ
暗証番号を知って その人は死んでからも誰か知り合いがね
お金を下ろしちゃっても捕まります
調べたらすぐバレますからね
何時でお金をおろしたかと
その時間 その人は前の日死んでいるんですね
だからカードで暗証番号知ったからといってね
違反は違反です  家族だったら
その人生きている間でその人にも使えない
もう見受けできないんだから
お金必要なものは誰か知ってる人は銀行からちゃんとこの人の口座から金を下ろしちゃいますよ
これは許可の上だから犯罪ではないんです
心臓が止まった瞬間でやったらあかん
それから犯罪です だから財産はそんな程度のものだから
自分で生きている間で使ってくださいよと
生活するために 生活するためにそんなにかからないんだから
他この罪を直すためにね
施ししなさいよと この世の中のくだらん罪ではなくて
この大宇宙法則を犯した罪なんです
はい これお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは一言一言もないな
この神の言葉だけで だからあまりかっこよくない
そのように施しをして
自分でも財産を利用して
人々から非難を受けないで
だからドネーションとかね
そうやってこのドネーションする人々
ボランティアする人々のことは社会は批判しませんね
自分も贅沢に生活するんだけど
結構社会貢献する それだったらみんな素晴らしい人だと言うんだからね
社会に褒められて死後天界に生まれるんだよと
という これ一つの経典ですね
だからこの説法テーマにはあまり使えない経典ですよ
お釈迦様は何もおっしゃってないんだからね
だからわしはずっとこれを避けて避けてくるんです
スリランカの場合 お坊さんたちは先にそれを言うんです
アディタスメンアガーラスメン
もうはちゃめちゃ聞いてるんです
説法会でヤンニーハレティバージャナタンタッソホーティア
アッタンにね ノーチャったって大丈夫とかね
私は子供の頃からそれ聞いてないんです
なんか変やと思っていたんです
はい そこでもう一つの女神がお釈迦様に質問をするんです
キンタドーバラドーホーと
何をあげたらパワーを上げたことに体力とかね
上げたことになりますかと
キンタドーホーティワンナド
何をあげたらとっても麗しい美しい人になりますかと
すごいかっこいい美男美女になるために何をあげればいいかと
人知ってます 語が物質を取り出すんだからね
だから語をどんな風にコントロールすれば
すごい体力のある力のある人になるんでしょうか
あるいはとっても美しい人になるんでしょうかと
あげなくちゃいけないことも知ってます
その場合はキンタドツカドーホーと
気楽で幸福で贅沢に幸福に生きるために何を施せばいいんですかと
キンタドーホーティチャックド
目をいただくために いわゆる物事を正しく見るために
肉眼だけではないんですね
正しく物事を判断して
肉眼ではいいんです よく見えるためには何を施せばよろしいでしょうかと
コーチャサッバダドーホーティ
この項目ごとに面倒くさいんだから
すべてあげたということどういうことかと
そうできるでしょうかと
はい 項目ごとに あんたは美しくなりたい
だったらこれこれ施しなさい
あんた長生きしたいから
これこれあげてください
あんた健康でいたい じゃあこれこれを施したい
施さないといつまでもしんどいでしょう
項目ありすぎだから だからまとめて総合的に何をあげれば全部もらえますかと
パッケージで と神は女神は聞くんですね
それでお釈迦様は答えます
アンナドーバラドーホーティ
すごい体力のある体で欲しければ食べるものをあげなさい
それも宇宙法則にぴったし合うんです
他の生命も法則からいただいたもので生活しているでしょ
自分には何か食べるものだけあるんですね
だから私のものと思わないであげる
思わないでではなくて
思ったことは間違いだからあげる
そうすると 自分にとっては結構体力のある健康な体で生まれます
で ワッタドーホーティワンナド
すごく美女美男で生まれたければ
服を施しなさいと 着るもの
着るものって飾ることだからね
体をね で 見せるんだから
だからいい服もらったら
人々はもらった人はそれを気持ちよく着て
なんとなく見た目が良くなる
だから自分がその結果
自然法則の守りによって美しい人間になる
えーと ヤーナドーツカドーホーティ
幸福で楽ちんで贅沢したければ
贅沢に生きたければ車をあげなさいと
車というのは現代訳で
古い訳では車なんですけど
時代によって車の意味が変わりますからね
ブッダの時代ではそんなに大げさな問題じゃないんですね
牛車か馬車でしょ それあげちゃえば
今更自転車でも それも一つの車ですよ
あげれば自分がすごく楽ちに生活できるような恵みに恵まれる
ディーパドーホーティチャックド
明かりを施すと目が現れますと
あまり単純でわかりやすいね
だから人々はこれは明かりをいただいたら活動できるものはYES NO判断できますからね
よしあし判断できますからね
どうしても食べる時でも目で見て判断するでしょ
これ食べるか食べないかとか
他のものの場合では ほとんど目で判断するんです
良いものか悪いものかと
ですから 明かり 明かりを施しなさいと
善悪を判断できる 良し悪しの判断できる
ある目が利くということでしょうかね
そこで面倒くさいんだから
全部まとめてパッケージで幸福になれた人を何あげればいいんですかね
それを神が女神が聞いたんだから
ヨウチャ サッバ ダドーホーティ
ソーダ ダーティ ウパッサヤ
ウパッサヤっていうのは
お坊さんたちが住む あのちっちゃな庵
何でしたっけ？ 庵で大丈夫
庵 そんなに豪華なものでもないんだけど
で 家を差し上げれば全部パッケージでもらえますよと
そこは女神の質問に答えた
お釈迦様にとってはなんかあんまりにも品のない質問だからね
いわゆる欲に絡んだ質問でしょ
それでも法則を守らないと輪廻転生は正しくできないんです
お釈迦様は一行入れるんです
アマタンダドーチェソーホーティ
ヨッ ダンマヌサーサティ
誰かが真理を教えるならば
ダンマをアナサスっていうのは
ただ喋るだけじゃなくて
アドバイスする 指導する
アドバイスして指導して
人々にブッダの教えを指導してアドバイスするならば
アマタンダドーホーティ
その人はアマタンっていうのは不死
それをあげたことになります
それにはかなわないね
だから このもう不死をあげたことになるんだよと
だから結局はお釈迦様はね
施しでは私には叶う人はいないでしょって話ですかね
あと お釈迦様が施すダンマの施し
法施をしているんだからね
でも俗世間的にはそういう項目ごとに考えることも可能ですね
面倒くさいんですよ ですから
まあだから私のものは私のものと思うものはあげればいいっていうことで
それは単純にこのない人はものをもらいたくていう
品のない話じゃないんです
そのために世界は使っているんです
特に世の中で一番儲かる商売っていうのは宗教でしょ
で なんだらかんだらハンドパワーでもレッグパワーでもね
何でもいいんです もうあれでもうガン治してやるぞとかね
あれやこれやと言って
もうかなり儲かっちゃいますね
だからこの施し どんな宗教でもかなり賛嘆していますけど
誰も法則は知らないんです
施しはイスラム教でもあります
毎年 自分の全財産の 2.5かなね
パーセントあげなくちゃあかんです
でもわかっているのかい？と
わかってないんです どうやって 2.5パーセント決めたんですかね
だから金持ちのイスラム人が毎年結構な量を施しなくちゃあかんです
そうすると その人々はだいたいガーガーと言って
政府からその分は税金を減らしてもらいます
それ必要経費だからね
宗教上 例えば 5億財産ある人の 2.5パーセントって結構金額でしょう
だから本当にそうやるのかって問題がありますね
サウジアラビアのあの連中
本当にやっているのかと
まあお金は出してるみたいんだけど
それはテロリスト養成所に
世界中ね 学校に送るんですね
マドラサに それで先生たちも送るんです
お金出して それで宇宙法則を守ることになるかどうかはわからないんです
それでどんな宗教でもね
やっぱりキリスト教は微妙には言ってるんだけどね
あの施しの場合はね まあ微妙にニュアンス入ってますね
あなたのものじゃないんだよと
だからこの自分のものではない
もともとそもそも体も私のものではないということを理解するための施しをする
だから施しをする人が
あれ 体さえ私のものじゃない
え？どうなってるのか
それだったらとびっくりするでしょ
私ってものは何もないやと
お釈迦様困っちゃったよと
お釈迦 あのね お前バカ
お前ってものはないんだよと
気にすんなよと 初めからいなかったよ
あなたはと あ なるほどと
それで悟りなんです 自分がいないっていうことは体験
だから施しとして その境地にはすごい簡単に
というか 理解的に簡単には届きますけど
道は遠いんですけど だから瞑想してください
とにかく 施しばっかりで解脱に達するまでいったら
どこまでやればいいかと切りがないんだからね
瞑想する一緒はどうせもありますけど
まあちょっと時間が延びてしまいましたが
一応このポイントは一応ほぼ完了するところまで喋りたかったので
一応完了です 完了じゃないね
物事には完了ないんだけど
だいたいこの施しダーナの真髄
これ発見できる人はほとんど世の中でないんです
ただ あ あげればたくさん幸せでもらえますよと思っちゃうで
あれが法則違反なんです
もらいたい目的が もらうために自分がいなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからそこも違反です
くれくれと言わなくても
必要なものは無料に宇宙法則によってあります
自分が自分の業にふさわしい業っていうのは
箱入れ物だったら それに入るものは頂ける
しっかりと美しい水が流れる滝があってね
喉が渇いた だから滝丸ごと飲める？飲めないでしょうね
カップ一杯 あるいは手で取ってちょっと飲むだけです
自分に入る量でしょ はい
まあとにかく自然界の恵みは無料無制限にある
取ったらあかんです 取ったらあかんて
恵まれるんだからね 取るなよと
ですから勘違いして頭イカれちゃって
私 私と思う人々はとんでもない罪を犯しているんだから
重罪を犯しているんだから
もうどうしようもない
あんたすごい危険な存在やと
もう施しなさいよと言わなくちゃあかんです
その瞬間からその人の人生が好転します
何の秘密もないんです
何の神秘的なものでも何でもないんです
淡々した科学的な話です
我々は呼吸していますね
酸素が必要ですから 人間が呼吸する酸素がなくなったら困るね
困らないよ 酸素はいくらでもあります
しかし 自分の肺に入る量で十分でしょうに
困る必要はないんです
そこで我々は私のもので行ってハチャメチャ酸素を燃やしちゃうんです
法則違反でしょ？だから二酸化何だらかんだらカーボン CO2 がね
出すわ出すわ出すわ もうどうにもならん
そこで宇宙法則が腹が立って人々を苦しめているわけじゃないんです
宇宙法則やら宇宙の神様が腹が立ってコロナウイルス送ったわけじゃないんです
自分の行いの結果なんです
そうなってしまう そういうわけで
施ししたら恵まれるということは
そんな法則で 特別誰かが来て
はい あなたにたくさんご褒美あげます
あなた施ししまったからということじゃなくて
自然にその人は幸福になります
はい 話は以上です 頑張ってください
はいはい ナモタッセ バグトゥアトゥサンマサンブッダッス
ナモタッセ バグトゥアトゥサンマサンブッダッス
エーテーナ サッチャヴァッジェーナ
パータサンナタナッタイアン
ヤーディーダ ブータニサマーガターニ
ブッマ ニバーヤ ニワアンタディッヘ
サッデワ ブータ スマナーバワントゥ
アトーピサッカッチャ
スナンツ バシタン タッマイ
ブータニサーミ サッデ
ミッタンガロータ マー
ディアパジャヤ ディワジャラットーチャ
アランティーバリン タッマイ
デーラングタヤッパマッタ
ヤンキンチヴィッタミタワウランワー
サッゲーシュワーヤン
ラタナム パニタン アノーサマン
アッユ タターガテーナ
イダンピ ブッデーラタナム
パニタン ゲーテーナ サッチー
スワッティホートー マヤン
ヴィラーガン アマタム
パニタン ガラッティ サッキャムニサマントゥー
ナテーナダンメーナサマッティキンチェ
ダンピダンメーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
ヤンブッダセットーパリワンナイソチンサマディマナンパリカンニャマー
サマディナテーナサモーナウィッジャテー
ダンピダンメーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
エープッグラーッタサタンプサッターチャッターエーターニユカーニ
テーダッキネイヤー スガタッササーヴァカーエーテーソディンナーニマハッパラニー
ダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
エーソッパユッターマナサーダルレーナディッカーミノーホーター
サーサナッンゲーテーパッティパッターマタングウィガイアラッダームダーニップティン
マナーイダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
ヤティンダケーローパタヴィンセトーシア
ジャトゥッピワーテーピアサンパ
タトゥーパマングサッポリサンワダーピーヨ
アリーヤサッチャーニヤミッチパッサテー
ダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
エーアリーヤサッチャーニウィーバーヤンテーガッンベーラパンジェーナシュケーシ
ターニキンチャーピテーオンティムサッパマッターナテーパワンアッタマッンアーディヤンテー
ダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
サーワッサラッサンサンプダーヤタヤスワランマー
ジャイターパワンテーサッンカーヤディッティウィチキッチタンチャー
シーラッブタングワーピアタッティキンチェチャトゥーパヤー
チャムットーチャチャーヴィターナーニアバッブオーカートゥン
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
キンチャーピソーカッマンカローティ
パーパカッンカーエーナワーチャーウタチェッタサーワー
アバッブオーソータッサパティッチャーターヤ
アバッブターディッタパダッサウッター
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
アナッパグンベーアタープッシタッゲーキンマーナマーセーパタマッンキンキンケー
タトゥーパマンダンバワランアデーサイ
ニッバーナガーミンパラマッンイターヤ
イダンピブッデーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
ワローワラッニューワラドーワラーロー
アヌッタローダンマワランアデーサイ
イダンピブッデーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
キーナンプラーナンナワンナッティサンバワンウィラッタティッターヤティケーバワンミンテーケーナヴィーヤーヴィルッリッシャーラー
ニッパンティテーラーヤターヤンパティーポー
イダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンゲーテーナ
サッチェーナスアッティホトゥ
ヤーニダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンタリッケー
タターガタッンデーヴァマヌッサポージタンブッダンアマッサーマスアッティホトゥ
タターガタッンデーヴァマヌッサポージタンダンマッンアマッサーマスアッティホトゥ
ヤーニダブーターニサマーガターニブッマーニワーヤーニワアンタリッケー
タターガタッンデーヴァマヌッサポージタンサンガンアマッサーマスアッティホトゥ
エーテーナサッチャワッジェーナドゥッカーウーパサミントゥテー
エーテーナサッチャワッジェーナバーヤーウーパサミントゥテー
エーテーナサッチャワッジェーナローガーウーパサミントゥテー
カラーニーマッタプサレーナヤンダンサンダンパダンアピサメッチェサッンポージョ
...
ムドゥアナティマーニ サントゥッサコーチャ スパローチャ アッパミッチーチャ サッラウカ ウッティー サンティン
ヴィヨーチャ ニパコーチャ アッパガッボー クレース アナヌキッドーナチャ クンダン サマカレ キンチエナ ヴィンニュー
パレー ウパワデーヨン スキノーアケー ミノーントゥ サッビー サッター パヴァントゥ スキタッター
エーケー チパーナ ブータッテー タサー ワーサーワラーワーナ ワセサーデーカー ワーエー マーンカー マッジ
マー ラッサカーヌ カトゥーラー ニンカー ワーエーワ シッターエーチャ ドゥーレーワ サンティ アビドゥー
レー ブーターワー サッマヴェーシーワー サッビー サッター パヴァントゥ スキタッター ナパロー パラン ニプッベーターナーティ
マンジェータ カッタ チナンカンチェ ビャーローサナー パティガ サンニャーナーニャ マニャッサ ドゥッカ ミッチェーヤー
タニヤン プッタン アユサー エカ プッタ マヌラッケー ヴァンピ サッパ プーテー スーマナ サンバーベー アパリマーナン
イッタンチョ サッパラ カッミン マナ サンバーベー アパリマーナン ウッダン アドーチャ ティリヤンチャ サンバ
ーダン アヴェーラン アサミッタン イッタン チャラン ニシンノーワー サヤーノーワーヤーワ タッサ ヴィガタミッドー
エータン サティン アディッテーヤ ラッメータン ヴィハーラン イタマーロー ディッテンチャ アヌパダンマ シー
ラワー タッサテーラ サンパンナー ハーミー スリネイヤ ケーダンナイ ジャートゥ カッパ セイヤン クナヴェーティーティー
エーテーナ サッチェ ワッジェーラー ソッティテー ホートゥ サッバダー エーテーナ サッチェ ワッジェーナ
ホートゥテー ジャヤ マンガラング エーテーナ サッチェ ワッジェーナ サッバローゴ ヴィナッサトゥ サンマン
カロー マーヴィーロー メダン カロー マハーロー サラナン カロー ローカ エトー ディーパン カロー ジョティン
ジャロー コンダンニョー ジャナパー ムッコ マンガロー プリター サポー スマノー スマノー ティーロー デーヴ
ァトー ラティワッドノー ソーヴィトー グナサンパンノー アノー マダッシー ジャヌッタノー パドモー ローカパッジョ
ートー ナーラトー ワラサーラテー パドムッタロー サッタサーロー スメトー アッガプッダロー スジャートー
サッパラ カッゴー ピヤダッシーナーラー サポー アッタダッシー カールニコー ダンマダッシー
モヌドーシンダットーアサモーローケーティッソーワラダサンワロープッソーワラダサンブッドーヴィパッシーチャアヌーパノーチキーサンバイトーサッターヴェッ
サポーシュカダーエポーカクサンドーサッターワーオコーナーガマノーラナンジャローカッサポーシリサンパンノーポータノーサッキェフングオーテーサンサッシェー
ナシーレーナカンディメッタバレーナチェテーピトゥアンヌラッラントーアーローゲーナスケーナジャーティサンビーティヨーヴィワッジャントーサッバーローコーヴィ
ナッサトーマテーパワットワンタラーヨースーキーティーカーユコーバウェーバワトサッバマンガランラックアントーサッバデーヴァタサッバブッダアヌバーヴェーナサダーソッティバワントテーバワトサッバ
マンガ
ランラックアントーサッバデーヴァタサッバダンマアヌバーヴェーナサダーソッティバワントテーバワトサッバマンガランラックアントーサッバデーヴァタサッバサンガ
アヌバーヴェーナサダーソッティバワントテーナッカッタヤッカブータナンパパッガーニバーラノンパリッタッサーアヌバーヴェーナアンドーテーサンウパッダヴェー
ドゥッカッパッターチャニッブッターバヤッパッターチャニッバヤーソッカッパッターチャニッソーターアンドーサッベーピカーニヨーキッタワターチャアンミーミー
サンバタングンニャサンバタングサンベーデーヴァーアヌモーダンツーサッブサンパッティシッディアサンベーブッダワラッパッターパッチェカーンジャヤンアランアリ
ャンターナンチャテージェーナラッカムバンガミサッバソーアーカサッチャーチャブッマッターデーヴァーナーガーマヒッティカープンニャンタングアヌモーディットワ
ーチランラックアントーローカサーサナンアーカサッチャーチャブッマッターデーヴァーナーガーマヒッティカープンニャンタングアヌモーディットワーチランラック
アントーテーサナンアーカサッチャーチャブッマッターデーヴァーナーガーマヒッティカープンニャンタングアヌモーディットワーチランラックアントゥトゥンサダー
ティーデーヴォワッサトゥカーレーナサッササンパッティチェティーターマジョーラージャーバワトゥダンミコー
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい 回向の文  では 回向の文を皆さんでお聴きしましょう
回向の文 あらゆる生命に慈しみをもって真理を説かれた本師釈迦牟尼仏陀の聖なる教えに従い
我々がここまで積んだすべての功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 生きとし生けるものすべてが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
イッタータチャミーサンバタムサンバタムサンベーリーサンモダンツーサッブサンパッティシッディア
イッタータチャミーサンバタムサンバタムサンベーサッバーモダンツーサッブサンパッティシッディア
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカーニッバーナンパラマンワダンティーブッダ